hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Lake View cabin
collection if you all recall I played
Lake View what is this
I played Lake View cabin a long time am
I gonna have a gun yeah sorry
okay that's weird okay
alright then okay I don't understand why
that's a thing I just kind of got
dropped in okay hold the peak the sewers
Oh God
what the hell is going on here there's
not this neither a lake view or a cabin
I really miss those are horror fest Lake
View cabin three four and five
oh okay how do I have a box why do I
have a box hello are you a zombie you
look a little solid and sunken destitute
and horrible look you cabin three in the
world is this like some bizarre level
select some dystopian future where all
video games are actually horror movie
set mateys
oh good huh what happened to Lake View
cabin two O's II I don't have a Z button
Z hey there we go okay oh what's dropped
it okay oh I thought I was gonna drop
the puppy in the ocean I don't like well
oh I can press the button to switch up
doing the characters okay you're just
gonna sit there for a little bit I'm
gonna pick up this and figure out what
the hell I'm doing so anyway with legs
evil alright naked well that's not what
I was expecting
okay well I didn't know that was the
thing I could do I'm gonna be this no
I'm gonna be this late I'm gonna be this
guy cuz he's got a nice mustache and I'm
pretty sure this is the same guy from
the original game be red was here good
I'm glad
so if you remember the first game it was
it was weird like admittedly it was very
weird yeah oh no I get off there are you
so gross
I need that flashlight X are so weird
why is any of this any of this why is
any of this at all anything I'm saying
look guys it's gonna
in the river okay bye you have a good
day now grade wood chipper who's that
gonna murder okay
well that wasn't fun oh no I'm sad now
ah ah my face what the hell happened
then oh okay I can hide lying in wait
behind a tree oh oh this is much weird
Oh ah let me just bleed on the bed a
little bit owner how many places around
this I can bleed and why why did I do
any of this no I'm not gonna play a
guitar I'm just gonna smash it okay cool
okay I'm naked now is the whole front of
mine just ripped off
am I just a walking corpse I do not look
good oh okay okay here we go here we go
okay apparently apparently apparently
apparently apparently
well now everyone's not looking so good
in the puppy is dead
Wow what the hell happened I busted open
the cooler for some brewskis I didn't
get a key though so that was something
that guys sacrifice was totally not in
vain what in the hell just happened
I have no goddamn idea I mean if my
objective was actually to kill people I
guess I did good but I'm pretty sure
that's not exactly what I set out to do
why is there a total pool of skulls
getting a little more bizarre not much
more bizarre but a little bit at a time
okay I got a kidney I've no one okay so
okay okay
dirt dirt dirt okay so the eight was red
I don't know why I don't know why any of
this is Luke II don't know what I just
got still bleeding profusely everywhere
I want to be very clear about that I'm
very much bleedy bleah okay can oh I can
put on a mask this is just giving me the
heebie-jeebies because I have no idea
what's going on
okay I got a gun now I really don't know
if my objective was wanton murder but uh
here I go anyway oops nope need that for
things and stuff okay Wow I'm almost
dead now because my leg is gone oh wait
I picked up my leg oh okay I'll just put
that in the cooler for later and get my
gun back because that's what I really
want
okay so I can't go here this will kill
me if I do that
so excellent oh oh okay
maybe I can use teamwork to get that why
am i doing this this is what my parents
warned me about about going into the
woods everyone would just somehow kill
themselves because that's one like I
forget what that well what was the movie
like Dale and Tucker versus the EP
happened why did I oh why oh god I'm
naked bleeding I'm bleeding
naked ding what the hell this is so
bizarre everything about this is really
bizarre ok I guess I'm just gonna keep
going as a walking zombie skeleton
that's bleeding everywhere
until I find out what's gonna kill me
and why did he die you're lucky I'm out
of shells I guess because I just can't
stop murdering everyone why and what and
how man this is so as to be it just a
fun outing into the woods turn to dead
horrible
okay what do I do
literally what do I do Oh what happened
what's that what's happening you know
like you that whatever the hell that was
I haven't the foggiest idea man when the
murderer finally shows up because you're
not gonna have a job like hey well then
alrighty then I did not know about that
there's comfort in that never happened
he's not following me
I'm just hopping on one leg well you're
gonna die is the long and the short of
this but you're gonna crap all about in
here how about here don't ever find me
so long as I don't leave a trail of
blood behind me I'll be just a gay Oh
oh that's not good
you
I have to admit I was not prepared well
you your dog and your friends are dead
game over all right I've always wanted
okay so let me try to do that a little
bit better whatever the hell I did okay
cool so our objective is to survive the
night not kill each other before we get
to the point where we need things are
going bad cuz I don't remember lake V
well
Oh who was the wait wait wait a little I
saw that I saw that okay oh I saw that I
saw it okay so that's good that means
that there's an identifiable threat and
I know he's there so we do have to use
teamwork to try to get past this but
there's got to be poor goddammit I'm
such an idiot okay so this is a trap
this is literally a trapping and use
this to my advantage
hmm ah piss I'm such an idiot
god damn it okay Fido you just stay nice
and safe over there so I got to find a
way to build like this to get over there
because that's gonna be one of the best
things it's gonna be able to a B ok so
there's got to be like supplies that I
can pick up here we go just tools over
here go here pigs is hey yeah I'm doing
it okay [ __ ]
alright there's something no this week
structurally unsound okay so I need to
find something to put up there so that I
can go where I need to go mmm
crap well I'm spooky okay pick this up
put this down [ __ ] god damn it uh I'm
surprised I'm not dead yet okay damn it
what am I supposed to do I found
something okay I found like a piece of a
map or something so that's gonna be
useful hey you guys doing good over
there okay so I need to here we go
that's right I need to like there we go
okay what is this no that isn't this is
a dildo this is a really heavy sock made
us a shotgun shell okay in here it was
like a key come on come on
Oh zip sorry sorry sorry sorry didn't
mean it didn't mean it didn't mean it
yep hey so
oh oh oh I can pick people up that's
really handy I think all right let's
move everyone has a team over
let's move everyone as a team over to
where we need to go there's gonna take
forever
no not what I wanted okay here we go
everybody grab your partner damn it not
the partner I wanted to grab not that
either put the beer down for one second
what the bear down we gotta go onward
[ __ ] okay here we go
I don't exactly know where we're going
to but hey [ __ ] okay I will solve this
problem by putting this over there done
forever we're safe now why is everyone's
mouth hanging a gate okay stay there
they're gonna go in here up here out
here yes this is where we're gonna make
our stand
it's probably not gonna help me in any
capacity at least it'll be something
anything to do with anything we'll be a
little better than what I'm doing now
okay and now we wait I suppose we can
tell scary stories lower here once upon
a time alone was lost in the hidden
valleys of Romania there once lived a
little old lady in the woods all by
herself and in these woods this little
old lady loved the farm and baked goods
for the whole neighborhood she was
really nice and nothing bad happened at
all the end great story okay here we go
sooo so there's a zip line that can
zippity-doo-dah out of here in case we
need it
I suppose I mean it's the only objective
to be able to survive the night really
quiet maybe we should have all gotten
naked before this you know just as a
last effort why not Oh
oh crap well that was a mistake pick up
your leg get back up here you back of
her now I did not know that that was
going to happen she seems to be doing
awfully well for holding her own leg up
but she's a survivor is this singing I
think it was singing here comes the
zom-bone er
oh I think I saw something
oh no those leaves falling okay so far
so good
papi I forgot about bumpers oh I forgot
about buffers nup oh no honey someone's
gotta go get him
oh no someone's gonna go get him someone
has to go get him
Oh someone's gotta go get him rubbers up
what her sent her top huh oh god damn
damn break son of a [ __ ] off or
something hover bumper suffered bumpers
up or get back here bumper dumper you
can't be here this is it
bumpers up I'm moving you got you okay
come on pop it up we're gonna get to
safety
we're gonna get to safety no one's gonna
murder us Bubber silver gonna survive
we're goddamn surviving team oh crap
that was not good well what happened I
got buffered up lalalala
well maybe Oh is dawn breaking I think
dawn might be breaking no Dawn's not
breaking it's still dead of night crap
well this is uh is the thing maybe it is
it is it totally is oh that's not a good
fog that's like the opposite of what I
was hoping for hey morning we survived I
don't know what that means but we did it
all right all right all right all right
we did it
we did it guys we did it we did it it
was team effort go go team go
wait who did you go
okay I thought I was gonna go right into
the malls of death let's get naked
cuz meeting these hazards by myself is
gonna be very difficult
hello Bertie okay never mind then still
don't know how to get out of here she's
crippled he's got a puppy she's weird so
I guess I'm just stuck down here what
was that oh I see it now oh crap he said
he's dead
what's that okay who's just that easy
huh perfect little jack on two tractor
when I'm naked
bad things happen goddamn rake
yeah till you stay there with that hey I
got one leg but I'm not too unhappy okay
since you you're a hobbling lady you're
gonna you're gonna blaze a trail here
for the good of everybody
trust me it's really for the good of
everybody heard another bang bang bang
bang bang oh it worked okay it worked
Wow she ain't doing so good but least it
was for the good of everybody come on
Papa shut up we're gonna get out of here
we're gonna get outta here puppy shop oh
don't you worry a little bit I got your
back too bad I'm not naked
all right there little peppers nup I
don't know we gonna do over here but
we're gonna find out oh no I think it
needs gasoline puffing up sniff out some
gasoline or leave some alcohol for me oh
boy there's the shotgun shells that's
good is the axe which is also good I'm
gonna put you down poppers no sorry to
throw you didn't me do go get naked pick
up the action I'm good to go
who all's room hello put that over there
oh ha read about enter Oh Justin you're
sorry sorry oh okay all right II then so
the shotgun was in here well no not up
there over years over here I believe it
was
look some bear be okay when I get back
all right okay Lisa I should be able to
pass down any lock door Oh locked are
you Oh No
haha there we go ah my bear bear okay
look there boink good out there you dead
put it down get up here okay got it
okay now I can go get what I need to get
and did I mention that I'm er naked I'm
still really naked howdy ma'am how you
do a naked naked here we ran naked now
I'm gonna be ready further than that
Buell wait why am I sitting on a stump
not what I wanted not what I wanted
dammit what these are there's obviously
a box of shotgun shells here this is the
box of matches which it could be oh it
was matches okay I'll buy fire auto fire
poppers jump over double jewelry oh good
well Burt McGann new crisp that's
awfully nice the least I made a fire ahh
kind of well down ain't normal
I'm pretty sure that ain't normal there
only go see what's going on here welp I
got whatever the hell this is don't
really know but it can good well okay
and I'll get I'll have two people with
weapons now ah - is far better than you
still hot by that tree good luck to you
sir good luck I'm still naked okay so
what guy happening
hmm oh well then gee
ah
now what the hell happened okay what did
I get I don't know
what they'll give us beating me in the
face all right whatever getting dark
anyway well sorry about this donk
okay oh I got my weapon
I'm very naked in battle ready she's got
her weapon
she's battle ready and totally
unhindered okay we'll cover pull hook
that's not what I'm intended hmm this
guy's hiding over here so he's gonna be
fine
maybe he's grabbed a light or something
or a beer yeah that's better
this is the best way to go about things
naked drinking beer that's good stuff
whatever does that is yep yep yep yep
yep yep yep that's good Jim yeah that's
good stuff okay
maybe I can get the flare ah damn it god
damn it
tits well dad's gonna yeah burp you burp
there yeah all right okay
there's no barber job I forgot huh burn
up come with me
come here pump it up I may be extremely
drunk but I'm gonna save you
well okay then all right okay
probably this cuz I'm extremely drunk
I'll set you garish up you will you poor
dick Luda finish with my laughs I just
cut up that old leg well bad things are
gonna happen tonight I bet I'm just
betting a bet
probably oh no oh no oh thank you
poppers knob let me do I really didn't
mean to
oh no I'm legitimately sad horrible oh
crap
generator went out oh crap well that
ain't good sounds I think good sounds at
all find out what's going on
woohee that's going okay all right
they may be coming right through the
doorway okay we're ready ready ready I'm
ready
right I'm ready
whoo I'm ready ready for you ready you
ready oh god oh god oh god I'd best get
ready dude I'm going to run well leaving
him behind
oh we didn't go right into death you
still drink
oh god oh god oh god ah my leg broke
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
hide hide hide hi Bond Street hide hide
hide behind Rick Henn jury oh here we go
still live I think we're still alive
somehow oh god oh no oh no bra no bra
na na na
I turn this on while there's no power we
hit the rake suck on that you bow he's
not dead besides he's not zombies clamor
oh crap oh okay do or not do or die
you're done give me a rock give me some
give me some
Oh give me something Oh give me anything
maybe this foot takes off whoa crap okay
this ain't good
I ain't good ain't good and good I just
need to be able to throw stuff adam rapp
yeah could have been better
huh damn it oh crap oh crap oh crap crap
crap crap
okay
why does he sound like a baby okay okay
okay okay I think I still alive still
naked behind that tree totally unfazed
what a badass I'll just be here Ricky do
you're still here why are you still here
why is he still here you shouldn't be
here you shouldn't be here
crap I guess I guess it's just it then
no okay okay okay
I don't know what this is all this more
matches okay shades
oh yeah bruh oh boy oh he is still here
well ain't this just a life lesson on
bad juju there had to be more stuff here
you like that I bet you don't
this Oh flies water that's not helpful
oh okay the ovens on that's good okay
not good not good not good oh I'm gonna
do a kamikaze attack where to go where
to go
at all all right I gotta find a way to
kill him I don't know how oh forgot this
guy only has one leg he's not unfazed
crap that guy that guy looked bad all
right mr. wobbly man's gonna come get ya
because obviously I can't do anything
I'm gonna die
come here you [ __ ] come here you rat
bastard I'm gonna finish this oh never
mind that's what you get kids don't do
drugs not exactly what I was hoping
well at least I can make my death
musical Oh
mr. monster baby come back here and show
me what could be too pretty go where'd
he go I want to see you a song to sleep
Oh mr. monster baby you're a big [ __ ]
I'm gonna speak to [ __ ]
are you you come here you somebody here
for you
twitchin okay alright did it
tow that was late for you cabin I have
no idea how to play this I'm gonna play
it again later but I'm gonna look up a
walkthrough on how to play so I'm not
wasting you guys in time that was really
fun there's a lot of creative stuff here
and there's like other games in the
series it's really weird and bizarre so
there's probably a specific said oh hi
you weren't there before you're the guy
from the first game okay what market
darken so thank you everybody so much
for watching I will play this game some
more because it's really fun and weird
and bizarre and really creepy for some
reason it's really really disturbing and
awesome I love it
so thank you again everybody and as
always I will see you in the next video
literally physically impossible
okay go man go God with you